n'a pas les rôles par contre une petite
surprise pour chacun si c'est parce que
comme on vous regarde quasiment tous les
soirs et ma mère mes bas ont laissé les
wallons là on connaît on s'est amusé à
vous donner des petits sûrement en
espérant que ça vous fera sourire
franchement c'est par la doyenne ma
copine d'école il s'appelle alors les
amène à 3,7 à leur appel
alors bye qu'isabelle isabelle ce n'est
pas comme si une battante à la peur de
personne
on l'appelle jeanne larrouy jeanne d'arc
et jeanne d'arc ça y va bien passionnant
et qui n'est connu tout jeune je peux
vous dire que même kaka n'était encore
pucelle avait déjà reçu aucun appel ni
mari ni mes mains parce qu'il est beau
et jamais il est intelligent et un
talent maxime c'est comme neymar tout le
monde rêve de l'avoir dans son équipe
même s'il est payé à rien [ __ ]
kenza comprendra très bas ya benjamin
benjamin lazar benjamin alors benjamin
je l'appelle cahuzac
mais c'est pour ces histoires d'argent
ça rien à voir c'est tiago net ses
papiers si tu veux c'est parce que alors
belge accès parce que lui benjamin à
force d'abuser du viagra pour honorer
toutes ses conquêtes et ben il va finir
comme cahuzac y va en prendre pour trois
ans ferme avec le moose lui a dit c'est
facile c'est lui qui nous qui essayaient
bassil
[Musique]
par contre il part acquis vite très vite
fait le chargeur c'est ce que m'a dit
jeanne d'arc arraché à l'arrêt donner un
petit conseil michel
si tu veux en amour c'est comme sur le
plateau de thé pmp faut savoir se
retirer au bon moment à fait pareil
alors des machines à mon petit
jean-michel on a le droit
voilà sûrement qu'on aime bien de vendre
est rigolo c'est très rigolo alors
maintenant quand à 11 sur l'homme la
balayette la course de quart de sa coupe
de cheveux blonds qui s'est surtout
qu'on dit toujours tu l'as dans le
tunnel et m
[Applaudissements]
monsieur je ne saurais gonnet
excusez-nous sous la ceinture mais il
paraît qu ici vous êtes quand même s'en
est passé des choses mais pas porter mon
polo diaw s est adapté un petit peu la
clientèle nous n'avons talent jean
michel drucker on parle plus de 200
tonnes de deux leçons lurie enduit
d'accord ça ne pousse l'adapter alors
valérie soutiendrait tout de suite
appelé et la belle-mère la même si la
belle fille et moi la belle mère quelle
fille parce que d'abord allé très belle
quadra et puis passer surtout c'est que
wayne gamin rêve de tous
on est venu annoncer pour ça m'a
chamboulée c'est ce qu'a accepté
gentiment me faire un petit bisou à
saint-chamas sam éveiller des trucs que
ça du coup ça m'a mis là samama ça m'a
mis la puce à l'oreille du sia le rêve
le seul à lucien lurel avait déjà les
oreilles savent quelque chose
au final ou pas je te garantis jeu le
jour où les confond des étincelles terra
firma igor se poser sans lui
il a alors jean-luc alors en lb nomme
annoncé dit de moi que je pense 5,6 en
moins parce que c'est exactement mon
type d'homme à homme très discret très
propre sur lui
et puis alors du coup bah je les
appelais la bouillotte parce que
j'aimerais bien l'avoir dans mon mieux
pour mes longues soirées d'hiver
j'espère que ça me restera tout ce qui
nommera leur part contre gilles
j'appelle la glacière lui c'est le
contraire de la bouillotte j'aimerais
pas trop la loi dans mon dieu j'ai rien
qu'au jill non c'est pas ça
même j'avoue que physiquement il me
déplaît pas avrillas vit sa petite oie
für alle à godefroy de bouillon la cible
au stylo sinon c'est plutôt qu'il est
comme moyenne un sale caractère
savard tous les deux dans le même pull
savarese ait un sens oui c'est ta photo
mon petit jean
t'es devenu un peu là christine angot
tpm paiera c'est dommage parce que c'est
sûrement un service que tu me rendrai
non à christine
une femme comme ça qui est de mauvais
poil tous les jours c'est sûrement
qu'elle est poisse et câliner c'est
connu ça se savoure est de bon poil ya
rien de tel que de se faire shampouiner
le caniche toy faudra désormais le
toilettage convenu que ce stade il à
christian là vous aurez bien encore
parce que je vois pour décocher une
autre les deux yeux tu as tu vas te
retrouver que la gueule des bogdanoff sa
peau de bella qui continue à me chercher
pour faire comme géniale idée joie de
déshériter face à leurs pères ou nagl le
band a mano radiateur agathon n'y a pas
de donner un petit surnom la suite on a
des heures marquer votre comédie c'est
déjà la tête de turc est vrai par contre
une petite surprise pour elle après
trois oui aulas oui voilà alors on va
finir par le chef de famille a battu
serena très joli petit surnom va se
mettre à côté de la mort cyril les fois
qu'ils en syrie baban entendu on fait
tout le monde ici l'appel baba et mais
nous on t'appelle claque y naquit oui
alors pourquoi pas venir ou parce que
ben sedrine 50 étaient sympas et qu'on
aimerait bien avoir à l'apéro tout
leflux
voilà comme l'éclat qui exactement la
virile zaki c'est bien connu c'est aussi
des toutes petites sociale j'ai alors il
s'en cache pas lui quand il était petit
10 effet écourté m'associe comme quoi
pour être le patron il suffit d'avoir le
bras long même s'il restait un petit peu
[Applaudissements]
kelly a trouvé pour aller si je faisais
un truc j'attends qu'ils me vient en la
revoyant la sécu j'ai envie de la tuna
boule à neige bref parce que comme comme
le sel qu'on a sur la cheminée la
lyonnaise on l'a mis là pour faire joli
ouais à chaque fois que je passe devant
j'ai envie de la prendre de la retourner
la note
on s'est amusé à comparer les séries
compris comment qu'on parle aux femmes
parce que là que des femmes
il suffit pas de leur dit la vérité il
faut surtout leur dire ce qu'ils ont
envie d'entendre gaza ce froid parler
aux femmes y en a ici qui sépare les
jeux terminés pas lui c'est que c'est
moctar
[Applaudissements]
et montargis je n'y ai trouvé un petit
surnom alors est très affectueux je
l'appelle le trépied pourquoi le trépied
mesdames je vous laisse je vous donne
pas d'explication merci mokhtar c'était
super la dernière fois et depuis je fais
un peu la prothèse de hanche qui
grinçait le dentier qui branlent elle
serait super
merci mon moteur
[Applaudissements]